Welcome to Module Four — advanced training.
This is where you learn to optimize the way the papers do: better optimizers, learning-rate schedules, regularization, and fast data pipelines.
Start with the optimizer zoo.
For vision, plain SGD with momentum still beats Adam surprisingly often.
Adam adapts a per-parameter learning rate for you, and AdamW fixes it by decoupling weight decay from the gradient step.
But here's the thing — your learning-rate schedule usually matters more than which optimizer you pick.
A constant learning rate plateaus early and wastes epochs.
Step and exponential decay are simple but dated.
The modern default is cosine annealing with a short warmup, and the OneCycle policy can give you super-convergence at a surprisingly large rate.
Run an LR range test to find the highest stable value first.
To fight overfitting, reach into the regularization toolkit.
Dropout zeroes activations at training time only.
Weight decay penalizes large weights, while L1 also sparsifies them.
Label smoothing softens those hard one-hot targets.
And early stopping simply remembers your best validation loss and restores it.
Normalization deserves its own moment.
Batch norm normalizes across the batch — great until your batch is tiny.
Layer norm works per sample and is the default inside Transformers.
Group norm is the batch-size-independent middle ground, and instance norm shows up in style transfer.
Finally, make it fast.
Mixed-precision FP16 buys roughly a one-and-a-half to two times speedup on modern GPUs, with a loss-scale optimizer guarding against underflow.
Build the input side with tf.data — prefetch, cache, and AUTOTUNE — scale out with MirroredStrategy, and always profile before you guess where the bottleneck is.
Let's benchmark optimizers and schedules — open the labs.